[Music]  can you hear me  this is captain max cloud do you read  over  [Music]  okay then who wants the first dance  max cloud is here  dad playing those damn games  i could just play video games all day  every day  okay so keep it together is this real  can i touch you  pull yourself together soldier we don't  have time for this what  beer is not near cowboy is here  i'm pretty sure i'm kind of freaking out  right now  so look out  sarah can you hear me shouting  literally no one was shouting  [Music]  the game you might actually have a  chance of getting out of here  the fate of the universe lies in the  hands of max cloud  did i say the universe again you were  [Music]  fantastic  [Music]  you